what went to your mind uh when you heard
the news that russia had attacked that
shopping center well of course the news
broke as we were all in the
the g7 sessions and you could feel the
whole mood of the meeting become yet
more
uh somber i think people are just
shocked by what putin is capable of of
doing
and
you know if anything it helped those of
us who are making the case for uh
helping to protect
the ukrainians
to get that message across to
some of those people who
are more swing voters in the argument
they can see that this is utter
barbarism and
uh
i think one of the things we've seen in
this g7
today is a really really powerful sense
of of unity and resolve and purpose and
uh
absolute determination to keep giving uh
the ukrainians the
the help the support the wherewithal uh
to keep going i've been there there's
been a strong message on unity but have
you been disappointed there's been a
lack of concrete actions on ukraine no i
think today you've just got another 30
billion dollars of uh humanitarian and
economic support for ukraine to say
nothing of the
extraordinary list of uh material of
equipment uh that everybody is sending
across and so what people basically
agreed on which i think had been
slightly perhaps questioned around the
world but i i was never really in doubt
in in my mind what we agreed on was uh
to give
the ukrainians the strategic endurance
they need
to try to to shift the dial uh to try to
change the dynamic of the position
that's what needs to happen that's what
uh vladimir zelinski uh wants us to give
him now the new head of the british army
general sanders is saying today that we
are the generation that must prepare the
army to fight again in europe says we're
facing our 1937 moment that's pretty
alarming for viewers to hear
are we preparing for war with russia
i don't think it will come to that and
clearly we're working uh very hard to
make sure that we uh confine this to
to ukraine i think the
putin
and the
he's going to the kremlin are going to
try to to widen the uh the conflict and
to try to say that this is a uh
something to do between nato and uh and
russia that's not it at all this is a
this is about uh an invasion of an
independent uh
sovereign country uh it's about the the
the west and all the friends of ukraine
giving them the support that they need
to protect themselves that's what this
is about now
when when it comes to uk defense
spending clearly we have to
respond to the way the threats uh
continue to change but don't forget
dominic the win we've now got a uh
defense budget that's 24 billion pounds
bigger under the spence spending review
the biggest increase uh in uh defence
spending since the end of the of the
cold war
whether you know last year the uk was
the third biggest defense spender in the
world but your defense secretary making
massive commitments your defense
secretary is reportedly asking for more
he wants 20 more over the next five
years is he going to get that well like
i
don't comment on you know leaked uh
stuff but what i can tell you if you
look already at what wedding last year
2031. uk the third biggest defense
spender in
what we're doing now under the uh the
spending review is putting uh another uh
24 billion pounds in uh
we're
we're well over two percent uh what we
wanted and we treat
the the two percent as a floor uh two
percent of gdp spent on defense we treat
that treat that as a floor uh not a
ceiling and that was a campaign by the
way that was began uh by the uk uh in
cardiff uh
at a nato summit and now i've seen many
more other countries come forward to to
match our spending so the point i would
make to people thinking about this at
home is not only are we stepping up to
the plate not only are we putting more
money into our armed forces but actually
as a result of our actions our lobbying
our campaigning our friends and partners
around the table in in europe in nato
are also putting much more and that is
so it's that cumulative uh increase in
investment that is very powerful and
very important but nothing more on top
of that is what you're saying in
response to what the defense secretary
seems to be saying which is he needs
more for britain to be ready for a
potential war with russia so as a result
of what we've already uh committed uh we
we put the biggest increase uh since the
end of the of the cold war where we're
meeting our uh pledge i think we've more
than met our pledge uh so far to uh
exceed uh the the two percent uh
floor uh that we want and we're the
point i'm trying to get over to to folks
is that we're not only just a a massive
uh defense spender contributor
but because of the campaigns we've been
running
we've got our friends i'm looking um and
past what's happening in germany the
massive commitments of olaf schultz is
is now making it it's by working
together that we can really start to uh
leverage national contributions and
make sure that
our continent is well protected um
talking about domestic issues which
you've been able to escape for a few
days uh here nicolas sturgeon is going
to lay out plans today for a second
independence referendum referendum she
said she has a mandate to do so because
of a victory in the election last year
can you stop her oh of course we'll see
what she has to say and uh you know look
forward to that i think an important
point to make is that um you know
we think the number one priority for the
country is the economic pressures the
spikes in the cost of energy uh our plan
for a stronger economy uh certainly
means that uh we think that we're
stronger working together but we have
good relations with the scottish
government we'll see what she has to say
will you block our plans to have another
referendum we said you can take it put
it in this way we certainly think that
uh our plan for a stronger economy works
better when the uk is together than when
it isn't together and
let me put it that way you said
yesterday that the leadership question
was settled in your mind but there'd
been reports overnight that
several of your mps are in talks with
labour about defecting worried about
their seats clearly not thinking you're
a great election
winner anymore that must be painful to
read
um how do you feel about that how does
it make you feel this i think this
really falls into the category of uh
of you know political commentary which i
leave to distinguish you know
journalists such as yourself it's simply
commentary is it that several members of
your party are thinking of leaving a
party and joining labour i think it's my
job to talk about our policies what we
have to do what we're doing for the
country uh what's been going on at the
g7 but you know there are plenty of
people who've been off
an opinion on that if i could put you
the views of a voter i met who's a
staunch tory supporter he's a self-made
man he said he's voted conservative all
his life he says when you next meet the
prime minister can you say to him i will
never vote conservative again because i
don't believe a word the prime minister
says
if you've lost people like him
are you finished is your party finished
i'm just gonna with great respect repeat
what i've already said
you know these th there are plenty of
people who can offer
political commentary
that's what they're paid to do
but does it not show that if these mps
are thinking of defecting that question
is not settled i think my job is these
are these are matters for commentators
my job is to get on and deliver the
agenda we've got it's a massive agenda
i'm very excited excited by it we're
making a huge amount of progress on all
sorts of fronts i'm going to leave that
to you on the northern ireland protocol
former prime minister theresa may said
in the comments yesterday that the bill
wasn't legal under international law
won't achieve its aims and will diminish
the uk standing in the world
how can you sit around a table with
other leaders doing business with them
if you are breaking the law if you are
breaking international law and are they
taking you seriously
well
first of all i think that the
most interesting thing about the last
few days is how
little contrary to some of the
suggestions have been in the in the uk
media or uk politics how little that
issue has been raised if at all
and i think
the other thing is that
our priority which i think people really
do understand
is the belfast good friday agreement and
that's what that's the higher uh legal
obligation
it's the balance of the uh of peace and
and stability in in northern ireland the
balance between
the communities there people get that
and i think people basically want to
move forward
just one more about ukraine and your
efforts to get grain out of ukraine
we've interviewed ukrainian farmers we
were in somaliland last week as well
talking to people that are deeply
worried about an impending famine what
the farmers are telling us today i was
in touch with one today was that to get
the grain out over land is just not
going to be enough you've got to open up
the ports you said
is that realistic can you open up those
ports to get all that grain out to those
starving africans and people around the
world who need it look i i the there are
all sorts of plans we're working with uh
with the turks and uh and others many
others to to try and see what the uk can
uh can add we're good at demining we're
good at ensuring shipping there's all
sorts of things that we're trying to uh
to add but i think the key message that
the world needs to hear about this and
you know it's not just in our country
but
around the world
the person who's stopping the grain come
out from ukraine it's not western
sanctions it's it's putin i mean he's
the guy he's putting the blockade in uh
he's blowing up uh bridges uh i think
there are
routes that you could
you could explore in addition to the to
the black sea i think
we could do more and more and we i think
in in uh it looks as though we did about
2.5 million tons of uh a grain from
ukraine last month that's a big increase
on on previous months uh and there are
certainly roots up uh up the danube or
by railway where you could where you
could step things up but fundamentally
as long as putin is
holding that grain hostage 23 25 million
tons
it is going to be very difficult and i
just think it's crucial that uh the
global audience understands that you
know it's down to him said the only
solution really is beating him in this
war i think that it's very difficult you
know
if he if he does the right thing if he
understands that people need to be uh to
be fed and that grain needs to come out
that beer that would be
a good thing but
i think we as i've said before i do
think that we need uh to have a
um
a plan b thank you very much prime
minister thank you thank you